I can communicate at least as well as a
tree so it's great being here at this
workshop on compositionality
compositionality is a very broad subject
I find it fun trying to explain to
friends what this workshop is about I
say it's about taking little things and
sticking them together and getting
bigger things that's the what the
workshop is about and let's see if I can
yes so the kind of things I like to
stick together to form bigger things of
the same sort our networks so in many
different areas of science and
engineering people use diagrams of
networks which are basically little
boxes connected by wires of different
sorts so a very classic example is
electrical circuit diagrams which
basically most of the machines in this
in this room have been designed by first
producing a diagram of this sort and
then instantiating it but there are many
others so this is a a actually a Petri
net but being used for a model of the
HIV infection of by the HIV showing
different states of white blood cells
and the virus and how they interact in
biology they use a lot of different
graphical networks and graphical
languages involving networks in fact
they have so many different kinds that
there's a committee now called the
systems biology graphical notation
committee that's tried to standardize
these and have come up with three
languages that they think cover most of
the things they they want to talk about
so this is some interesting biological
mechanism called the repressilator where
each one of these reactions represses
the function of the previous one and in
control theory which is the art of
getting mechanical and electronic
systems to behave in a in a stable and
robust kind of way they use something
called signal flow diagrams
the simplest sort of thing would be a
thermostat the signal comes in which
would be say the temperature of the room
and then the thermostat will affect
whether the furnace is turned on and of
course then the furnace affects the
temperature of the room and you have a
feedback loop and that looping is the
key idea in control theory to try to get
feedback loops to do what you want
so I've loved diagrams of networks ever
since I started trying to think about
Fineman diagrams in a mathematical way
and trying to think about generalizing
them to quantum gravity and the
relationship of them and category theory
has always been fascinating to me but
now I'm trying to do slightly more
practical things which isn't saying much
really and and and so I started eyeing
these other kinds of network diagrams is
something to investigate and I really
think we need a good general theory of
these first of all because these
different languages are developed by
practitioners of different fields
through art mathematicians and they
think of what they're doing is their own
personal or their own personal property
of their own community of researchers
and thus they don't develop them at the
level of generality that makes it easy
to transfer their results to other
fields so for example chemists have done
a whole lot of work where you can look
at a chemical reaction Network and in
for properties about the stability of
the chemical reactions without having to
solve a bunch of equations and those
models of chemical reaction networks
also can be reinterpreted as models in
other areas like evolutionary game
theory where you have different
populations interacting with each other
but because the chemical literature is
all under the name of chemical reaction
networks it would take and then the
terminology is all in the terminology of
chemistry it would take a somewhat
intrepid evolutionary game theorists to
to realize that they should start
reading all these chemistry papers to
find these stability theorems that they
could use in evolutionary game theory
now it's not clear of course that making
things in the language of category
theory actually eases
communication between evolutionary game
theorists and chemists but I'm trying to
explain things to different people in
different ways and hopefully if enough
people do that we will get some
communication going in this particular
workshop I somehow perhaps erroneously
probably erroneously thought that lots
of people with no category theory and so
I could finally come out and say what I
really mean but we'll see how well that
works but Lee says a certain number of
you are experts in category theory and
the rest of you should ask questions and
things so the idea of categories
how does category theory play into this
is that networks of some particular kind
so fix some particular type of network
if you specify some input and output
nodes in your network you can think of
that thing as a morphism in a category
so so here I have a here on my networks
are just a graphs just a set of vertices
and set of edges where each edge is
directed and the way I'm specifying some
of the vertices as inputs is by a map
from a set to into the set of vertices
notice I'm not demanding it that it be
one-to-one that's a little rough subtle
point which you don't have to worry
about too much really and then why is
some other set which is beginning mapped
into this set of vertices and that ribs
the outputs of of the of the network and
the point is that then we can think of
this as a morphism from X to Y and then
if you have a morphism from Y to Z we
can compose them by sticking together
the output vertices of the first network
with the input vertices of the second so
in a category you can compose morphisms
and this workshop is really all about
that hence the term compositionality in
fact this is going to give you a
symmetric monoidal category which means
that in addition to being able to
compose morphisms one after the other
you can set them side-by-side which is
called ten suring them and that lets you
discuss processes being done in pair
as well as the ones being done in
sequence so the nice thing is that
networks of this sort let us describe
open systems so there's this concept of
open system that I can tell already a
lot of you understand but let me just
try to say what an open system is it's a
little hard to to define in generality
but it's basically a system where stuff
of some sort can flow in or out of the
system so stuff could be energy
information signals of various sorts a
matter if you're studying chemistry you
may have a pic of that of chemicals but
you're actually at pouring noir new
chemicals in or pouring them out which
is what you'd be doing in a chemical
production process are you trying to
manufacture some chemicals so stuff in
the most broad sense can flow in and out
and you're concerned with that fact and
then you can combine open systems by
composition that is feeding the outputs
of one into the inputs of the other or
ten Tsering setting them side-by-side so
so so the language of symmetric non-oil
categories is the right language for
discussing open systems of the in this
sense and what people do is they use
network so these diagrams of networks is
a syntax for open systems and then use
the ideas of func toriel semantics which
luckily Prakash already explained
yesterday to interpret those networks as
and figure out their meaning so levere I
guess in 1963 came up with this idea of
func toriel semantics and in this
context what it amounts to is that you
think of networks of some particular
type like electrical circuit diagrams or
whatever as morphisms in some particular
symmetric monoidal category say X and
that will be your syntax and then to
interpret a network we use symmetric we
choose a symmetric monoidal functor F
say from X to some other symmetric
monoidal category and that category will
be good for what we call semantics or
endow me
to the diagrams which are the morphisms
in X so the classic examples of
symmetric monoidal categories that you
might use for semantics would be the
category of sets and functions or the
category of sets and relations so if you
use the former than every Network every
morphism and X would get sent over to a
function over here which is a morphism
it's set and the meaning of that is that
we think of our we the the the the
interpretation of our network is that it
describes a function from some input
data to some output data but very often
we want to use other categories besides
the category of set very often you might
just want a relationship between the
input data and the output data the input
data may not interpret may not determine
the output data they may just need to
obey some relation and there many other
variants of this idea but that's that's
the that's the what's I claim is going
on in all these disciplines when people
are drawing diagrams like Fineman
diagrams or electrical circuits is that
there is that secretly in mind that the
although they wouldn't phrase it this
way they have a symmetric monoidal
functor in mind which lets them
interpret the diagrams as having some
meaning and the point is that working
with a diagrammatic notation is more
convenient often than the traditional
linear symbol string notation so how can
you actually build symmetric monoidal
categories with networks as the
morphisms how can you start doing this
so one way which isn't the main way I'll
be talking about is the sort of
algebraic approach using generators and
relations so the idea is that you can
present just as you can present a group
by giving some generators and relations
you can present a symmetric monoidal
category so it's a category has some
objects and morphism so what we do is we
pick a set of generating objects so you
start with some objects and then you
build up other objects by ten suring
those so if you think of an object as a
dot ten suring it would be like putting
a bunch of dots side by side and then we
also need to give a set of generate
morphisms you could think about a
morphism as like a network so you can
very generating one might be some simple
network like where two things come in
and one go out and the way we use them
to generate more morphisms is by 10
Tsering in composition so you take those
little building blocks and you start
assembling them vertically and
horizontally to build big complicated
networks and then as always in a
presentation you would want some
relations and typically here we would
only impose relations between morphisms
saying that something is equal to
something else some diagram we counted
as being equal to some other diagram so
there's a nice way to go about this and
the advantage of it is that then you can
describe symmetric monoidal functors
between symmetrical monoidal categories
by just saying where the generators go
so if you've ever studied groups using
generators and relations you know
they're like what do you actually do
those generate leaders and relations
well one thing you do is you describe
group homomorphisms
to be in the following way you just need
to say where each generator goes and
check that the relations that held in
the original group still hold over here
on the images of them so you do the
exact same trick to construct a bunch of
symmetric monoidal [ __ ] like these
ones that assign the meaning to networks
now this method is a little bit it takes
a lot of work it gives you a lot of
insight if you can succeed it takes a
lot of work because often if you start
with a symmetric monoidal category where
the morphisms are some very simple
pictures like that graph I showed you it
may not be obvious what the generators
and relations are so for example in the
case of the one that I just showed
before this the plain old directed
graphs directed multigraphs to be super
precise Rosenberg's Sabbatini and
Walters came up with the generators and
Relations description of that symmetric
monoidal category but it took work to do
that so there's another approach which
has what I mainly want to talk to you
which Brendon Fung worked out
which is using some technology we called
decorated coast bands so let's look at
this same network that I showed before
and we'll think of it this way
for starters it's called a it's a KO
span of finite set so a coast band is
just a diagram that looks like this
where you have two objects here both
mapping to the same object here in this
case s is the set of all vertices of
this graph and I and O for input and
output are the functions from these sets
x and y into s so that would just so far
be talking about the vertices and
nothing about the edges but the idea of
a decorated coast band is that we want
to take this object here in this case
this finite set s we want to decorate it
with some extra structure which is the
app structure present in our network
whatever that may be in this particular
case the extra structure is that is that
we've got a graph here not just a set of
vertices so the extra structure is to
say we don't just have the set s we also
have a set of edges and every Edge has a
source and target each each edge here
has a source vertex and a target vertex
and so what Brendan did is come up with
a nice technology for constructing
categories where the morphisms are
decorated coast bands so you have to say
how to compose them it will be symmetric
monoidal category so you have to say how
to tensor them and you want to be able
to do various nice things with them that
are the kind of things you want to do in
network theory but I want to show you
how this works and I want to use a
somewhat more interesting example than
the example of graphs so I'd like to use
Petri Nets so Petri net is just a
bipartite graph meaning that there are
two kinds of vertices which are these
red circles and these green squares here
and the two kinds of vertices have names
that are supposed to be evocative so the
the the red circles will call places so
we could think of those as like little
bags where where you could put put some
rocks
oh and then the green things we call
transitions and so the idea is here is
little F I have a rock in this place on
a rock in this place that can go in
that's what these arrows mean through
this transition something happens and
then something pops out one one one
thing pops out and goes into this circle
here or similarly one thing of this type
could go into this transition and then
turn into two things of this type so pet
peanuts have been around for quite a
long time in fact although they became
popular in computer sciences models of
concurrency starting in the 70s maybe
the 60s I don't exactly sure they're
actually apparently invented by Carl
Petri when he was a teenager in 1939 as
a language for chemistry that's that's
what legend has has it anyway if you
read Wikipedia it says the legend is
that this is the case so I don't know
that sort of makes you wonder if it's
really true or what but so so here's a
Petri net used for the purposes of
chemistry and they are now still used
for further purposes of chemistry and
that's actually more that's closer to my
motivation because I claimed no
knowledge of of computer science I'm
more more of a physicist and chemistry
is close enough to physics that I can
sort of encroach on that territory
without getting too nervous so you've
probably seen chemical reaction networks
you may not have noticed that those are
pictures of morphisms in a symmetric
monoidal category where the objects are
the different kinds of chemicals called
chemical species and the tensor product
is written as a plus just to confuse you
or something and and then the arrow is
the name of the morphism the going from
from something to something else but in
addition to that style of drawing
chemical reaction networks you can also
draw them as a Petri net and and so here
we have a reaction that takes a carbon
atom in a molecule of oxygen and out
pops one molecule of carbon dioxide and
so on
and there are certain advantages to this
style of drawing and certain advantages
to this style of drawing chemists
theoretical chemists have all sorts of
theorems about the stability of systems
of chemical reactions and and like
whether they engage in cyclic behavior
or converge to an equilibrium or
whatever based on the topology of the
network and some of the theorems use
this style of network as the basis of
the theorem and some use this style so
they're both very interesting so the so
you can imagine if you're trying if
you're trying to get a little closer to
the computer science picture of things
you can imagine a bunch of little
markers or tokens in each of these
places at any given time and then as
time passes on those tokens go through a
transition and pop and new tokens pop
out as a way to keep track of how many
atoms or molecules you have of various
kind so but they're used in on many
other fields so I was at a talk on on
the on AIDS and they used this model of
the infection of white blood cells by
virus particles an individual virus is
called a very on so you could have like
a very on meeting a healthy white blood
cell infecting it by means of this
transition beta and then out pops an
infected
white blood cell which then may emit
more virus particles or it may die and
so on and what they do in these in this
kind of discipline is they take this
kind of diagram and then they translate
it into a system of ordinary
differential equations that describes as
a function of time well how the number
of these various entities in your places
changes with time so this is a syntax
for describing ordinary differential
equations and you could just write down
the ordinary differential equations and
not draw this picture but this picture
somehow is easy makes it easier to
understand what's going on and it's
it's compositional in the sense that you
can stick together these pictures to get
fancier pictures which is really a way
of sticking together systems of
differential equations to get more
differential equations but that's what I
want to talk about so in systems biology
they they use these quite a lot so I'm
already forgetting this is something
about the operation of a muscle they
have a very complicated Petri Nets and
many other fields they're used ok so so
let's describe how you can get some
differential equations out of a Petri
net well you need a little bit more
information you need a Petri net with
rates by which I mean that each
transition is given is attached we
attached to it a positive real number
called it's rate constant which somehow
describes how how fast or how likely it
is for that transition to occur and then
from that data we can write down a
system of differential equations which
call the whole system we'll call it the
rate equation describing dynamics so for
example if you take this Petri net here
we get this system of differential
equations so to write that system down
I'll give names to these two these
different places and I will think of
those names there's also denoting real
valued functions of time which describe
how much of that item you have so now
here I'm using a 1 to mean how much of
this stuff we have and we're assuming we
have got enough of it so that we're not
counting atoms in an integer manner
we're just counting the concentration of
a chemical as as a positive real number
and the idea is that we write down the
system of differential equations showing
how they change with time and so for
example this transition here says if a
if a thing of type a1 meets a thing of
type a2 they can turn into an a3 and
they have a they do so at a rate
proportional to R 1 so that means these
a ones will tend to go disappear they'll
tend to go away which is why there's a
minus sign here
and it's you get minus R 1 a1 a2 so they
can only go away if
than a1 and a2 or present so in
chemistry you get this law called the
law of mass action saying that that
happens at a rate proportional to the
product of the of the chemicals that are
going into the reaction so similarly a2
is going away due by the same process so
we can see the exact same term here and
a3 s are getting created by by this
transition and so we see that the amount
of a 3 s is increasing by the same rate
but then we have this other transition
r2 that takes a single a3 and produces 2
a 2 s so that also has its effect so a 3
s are going on a way at a rate
proportional to to the number of a3 s
times r2 so notice that's just linear in
a3 because just one a3 is getting used
and then 2 a 2 a 2 s are getting created
in this transition so that's the reason
for this coefficient 2 so hopefully that
illustrates how it works and then you
could I could draw an arbitrarily
complicated Petri net label the green
boxes by positive real numbers and you
can just crank out this system of
differential equations called the rate
equation so that's what chemists that's
what chemists and other people do so so
this is the idea of the translation from
the syntax into the semantics in a
somewhat informal way which is the way
that people usually think about it ok so
so far these Petri nets are just
describing closed systems but you can
actually have open Petri Nets and I'm
gonna make a symmetric monoidal category
where the morphisms are open Petri Nets
with rates and I'll call that category
Petri so the objects will be finite sets
like the set X and the set Y and a
morphism will be a Petri net with rates
together with functions from x and y
into the set of places so so we we may
it may not be one-to-one if it's two to
one it may be a little bit confusing but
but the idea is that there could be two
different kinds of things that could may
be coming from two different places that
could go in here
so to compose these guys you do more or
less obvious thing so here I have one of
them going from X to Y the same one as
before I guess and here I have another
morphism G going from Y to Z so we have
a function from Y into the set of places
of our first Petri net but also into the
set of places or our second Petri net
and so we use that to say hey this we're
going to identify this place with this
place and we get a single place in the
composite Petri net so we just identify
the outputs of one with the inputs of
the next and then you can tensor
morphisms as well just by taking one of
them and another one and drawing them
side by side so you take the disjoint
union of the input sets the disjoint
union of the outside put sets and you
set the Petri net set by side by side to
get the tensor product in this category
so as I said you you get a rate equation
from a Petri net well an open Petri net
will give something that I'll call an
open rate equation which has some extra
terms describing flows in and out of the
of various things corresponding to the
various places here so if I had this one
here I would get this equation so I'm
what I'm doing now is as before laid
labeling the places with functions of
time and I'm also now labeling these
inputs with functions of time and the
these inputs functions of time do not
obey any differential equation because
the idea is that some external user
could decide to dump in chemicals of
various sorts at a rate that it was up
to them to decide so I one of t you
could say is the determine from outside
of the system and not it affects the
behavior of how much a1 you have but but
it doesn't but it's not determined by
any equations of its own and here I have
I 1 and I 2 coming in here so we have
both of those added up affecting the
amount of a to
and then by a sign convention that's
very useful over here
we put a minus sign in front of the O
one of t we need that sign convention so
that when we stick things together it
all works out nice oh you're right I
that's it that's a mistake so there
should be an extra term great that's
excellent so this maybe should have been
like the tests that I used to see if
people were paying attention but yeah so
there should be an expert what okay so
it's an exercise to figure out what I
did so so so so so art we should get a1
a2 times r1 showing up once here so it
should be plus that but also it should
be showing up twice here well I really
gum this up so this should be a 1 times
a 2 here yeah so I don't know this must
be the slide that I that I wrote after a
few beers or something like that I don't
oh you mean that was a okay I give up
okay so we'll fix this if necessary I
probably should have at least written a
1 squared it's sort of uncouth to write
a 1 times a 1 even if it's correct so
okay so hopefully that Illustrated the
idea by letting you all like see that I
didn't know what I was doing so the the
the Petri net part is supposed to work
exactly the same as before the only new
part is is is these input and output
terms so that's what I was really trying
to explain them they gummed up
everything else so so open Petri Nets
here are serving as a syntax with these
differential equations which are you
could call an open dynamical system
providing one possible semantics of them
so in the idea of form toriel semantics
we'd like to get a symmetric monoidal
functor from the symmetric monoidal
category Petri to some other one which
i'll called
where the morphisms are open dynamical
systems now computer scientists like
talking about territory nuts in
different ways they don't they don't
usually write down differential
equations from them so they would to be
looking at some other choice of
semantics and I claim that that would
give you some other symmetric monoidal
functor to some other category but I'll
just think about this one semantics here
so what is this category of open
dynamical systems well it'll be a
category where an object is a finite set
and a morphism is an open dynamical
system so what that will mean for me is
it's a Coast ban of finite sets so s you
think of here is the set of all the
places in our Petri net for example and
so there could be a real number attached
to each one of them that may vary with
time and to describe how it varies with
time we put a vector field on the vector
space R to the s so a dynamical system
is usually thought of in modern
languages as a vector field and so an
open dynamical system has has that
vector field on s but this additional
data would this input and output data
which is what lets us understand inputs
and outputs so the idea is that if I
have an input and output flow so an
input flow would be a function of time
taking values in R to the X and an
output taking values in R to the Y and
that's the wrong shape are there then
the open dynamical system would first of
all be would tell you how the amount of
each thing in our set s changes with
time and so it would be a differential
equation that for starters would involve
the vector field on s so so if I stop
there that would be just like a classic
dynamical system but then plus some
extra terms here so the idea is if I've
got a function on X real valued function
on X and a on a finite set X and I have
a map from X to s I can push it forward
to a real valued function on s by
summing the the values
of all points here to go to a certain
point here and that's what this
subscript star means it's pushed forward
so I I do that and then I subtract this
so this is just a abstract description
of what I showed you in the example so
that's the recipe so so I've been
working on this stuff with Blake Pollard
who is here he's right here and he had
here here's our theorem there's a
symmetric monoidal functor which I'm
calling box from Petri to dynam which
sends any open Petri net - it's open
dynamical system so the main thing about
this theorem is that this box thing
needs to preserve composition and tensor
product so being a symmetric monoidal
functor means mainly that you preserve
composition and you preserve tensor
product and so what this means is that
if we want to figure out the open
dynamical system for a composite of two
Petri Nets we can figure out the open
dynamical system for each one and then
compose in the category of open
dynamical systems and similarly for
tensor product so this is what
compositionality is all about
determining the behavior of a very large
complicated system by figuring out the
behaviors of its pieces and then just
gluing them together so that so so that
that's the key idea here so the question
though is how do you prove a theorem
like this so this is where Brendon
Fong's theory comes in handy so he has a
very general abstract way to get a hold
of such symmetric monoidal categories
and such symmetrical functors so we'll
start with a category C that has finite
Co limits like in our examples so far
it's always the category of finite sets
then you can build up then then you can
talk about coast bands in there and you
can compose coast bands and the way you
could post coast bands is called taking
a push out so you should think in the
the category of finite sets you should
think of this as first you take the
disjoint union of n and n prime but then
you identify a point in N with a point
in n prime if one of them is the image
of some point in Y under O while the
other is the image of that same point
under I prime so that's sticking first
taking the disjoint union of two sets
and then sticking them together gluing
them together so in case you're not into
categories push-out is just a fancy name
for sticking things together it's very
important if you're interested in
compositionality because of composition
sort of about sticking things together
so so it's known that this structure
gives you not a category with these as
morphisms but something a little bit
subtler called a by category because the
problem is that push out is defined only
up to isomorphism so that composition
doesn't obey the associative law on the
nose it only holds it up to isomorphism
so you get a structure where you need to
be able to say you need a fancy
structure to say that the composition is
preserved on composition sorry is
associative only up to isomorphism and
that's a by category but I don't want to
get so fancy so I'm just going to work
with a category called Co span of see
where the morphisms are isomorphism
classes of CO spans so I'll be glad to
answer questions about that later but
this is perhaps a little technical if
you're not into this stuff so then to
get decorated coast bands we'll pick a
functor from C to set and the idea is we
will try to build a category where a
morphism
is an isomorphism class of coast bands
where the apex the object on top is
decorated by an element of this set F of
s so in our example of Petri Nets X + y
+ s or finite sets s is going to be the
set of vertices of our of our of our
Petri net and we're going to start the
set of places in our Petri net and F of
s will be the set of all way
of taking that set s and thinking of it
as the set of places in some Petri net
so this decoration this element of F of
s is just the choice of the Petri net
that will be in our open Petri net
whereas the coast band tells you what
the inputs and outputs are so so the
question though is when you compose
these coast bands by push out how do you
compose the decorations how do you stick
the decorations together so suppose I
have got a coast band with some
decoration and another coast band with
some decoration so how do we compose
them well we composed the coast bands by
taking a push out which is what I
already explained and here's what we do
to the decoration so we've got
decorations D and D Prime living in the
sets F of s and F of s Prime there will
be in this example of Petri Nets and in
all the examples that Brennan is
concerned with a map from F of s times F
of s Prime to F of the disjoint union or
the co-product s F of s s plus s Prime
so what that's saying in our example of
Petri Nets is that if I've got a way to
to make s into the set of places of a
Petri net and similarly for s prime then
I get away to make s plus s prime the
disjoint union into a set of vertices
sorry places of a Petri net just by
sitting the two Pepsi nuts together so
this function here is technically said
to be the result of F being a lacks
monoidal functor a true monoidal functor
would say that this is isomorphic to
this in our example this is not
isomorphic to this in other words there
a lot more ways to make the disjoint
union of two sets into the set of places
of Petri net then come from doing it on
each part but we certainly get some that
way so you do have this function and
then because f is of
functor and we have a map from the
disjoint union to this push out we can
we get a map from F of the disjoint
union to F of the push out so this
justice says you take your your to in
our example this just says you take your
two Petri Nets you set them side by side
and then you stick them together where
the second set is the sticking together
part so so in general the theorem then
is this that if you have a category with
finite colum it's so that you can do
these push outs and you've got a lacked
symmetric monoidal functor then you get
a symmetric monoidal category of
decorated coast bands or F decorated
coast bands where the objects are the
objects of your category see the
morphisms are going to be coast bands
decorated but by an element of F of the
apex so that that's the general thing
that lets us get the category we want
well actually morphisms are not exactly
coast bands they're isomorphism classes
of them otherwise you would get a bike
category so then we can apply this all
over the place we can apply this to get
this category of Petri Nets which is the
example I've been talking about where
where the objects are finite sets the
morphisms are coast bands of finite sets
together with a Petri net with rates
having s is the set of places as its set
of places and again just kidding
it's actually an isomorphism class of
these things so a morphism in here just
looks like what I've been talking about
one of these kind of gizmos see that's a
trouble if you joke too much people
start wanting to know what the joke
means so how about if I say after
afterwards what that is there's a I need
to start drawing a little diagram to
draw an isomorphous I'll be glad to do
it but it's just some pathological
honesty that let me put this makes me
put this in in the first place and I'm
regretting it
so so sit you can use the same formal
method to get the category of that open
dynamical systems now you take the
objects to be finite sets and you take
the morphisms to be Co spans of finite
sets now though the apex here is
decorated with a smooth vector field on
our to the S so you can again check
using Brendon's theorem that you get a
symmetrical category this way that time
so you don't ask again and so so how do
you get a symmetric monoidal functor
which is this providing the semantics to
our open Petri Nets well Brendon has
kindly provided a theorem for that as
well so now suppose you've got two
decorated post band categories how do
you get a nice functor from one to the
other so you have a category with finite
colum it's in two different lacked
symmetric monoidal functors f and g
which is what thus give us two different
decorated coast band categories well
there's a thing that goes that likes to
go between lacks symmetric monoidal
functions which is called a monoidal
natural transformation and so if you
have one of those then you get a
symmetric monoidal functor from F
decorated coast bands to G decorated
coast bands so this is the power of
abstract nonsense coming in here those
of you who are who are into categories
will what to say yeah yeah this is just
how it's bound to go but it takes work
to prove it once you prove it then you
get all sorts of things without further
pain so what Blake and I wanted was this
symmetric monoidal functor from Petri
Nets to their dynamics and so that just
follows as a one of millions of
corollaries of Brendan's general result
and so that you can do this not just for
these open Petri Nets with rates but
many other kinds of networks so let me
just list a few different kinds of
things we've been looking at so what I'm
trying to do now is sort of row more
the landscape of different disciplines
that use diagrams to describe complex
systems and see what mathematical
framework is the right one to fit them
in on I don't really want to try to
force them into some framework that they
don't want to be in but if they're happy
to be in the framework of decorated
coast bands then I'll count that as a
check on my my my little notebook as a
success so the before we got into this
open Petri Nets which involve nonlinear
differential equations we started
Brendon Fung and I started looking at
electrical circuits which involve linear
differential equations and thus here I'm
drawing the simplest kind just involving
resistors which you don't really have
differential equations at all you just
have linear equations relating the
currents and voltages of the system so
we all understand everyone who cares
about Electrical Engineering keraton
understands about circuits made of
resistors but what we're focusing on
here is the fact that we could have
inputs and outputs and that we could
compose these intensities so we get a
symmetric monoidal category of circuits
made of resistors and then more
generally of other kinds of circuit
elements in this paper we're focusing on
passive linear circuit elements so we
have things like inductors and
capacitors as well then all three of us
me Brendan and and Blake teamed up to do
something similar for Markov processes
so Markov process will have a bunch of
states and then rates for something to
hop from one state to another state
which you can think of as a random
diffusion process and so we define a
concept of open Markov process where
stuff can flow in or out from the
outside and then these open Markov
processes can be composed and ten surd
so we get a symmetric monoidal functor
here and again symmetric monoidal
category here and again a symmetric
model functor that provides the
semantics to this syntax to these
pictures here and then my student jason
herbally did
his thesis on categories in control
theory and so but schinsky Pavlovich in
ski has also worked on that and Brendan
Fong has worked or worked on that and
his thesis is actually the best place to
sort of get a broad overview of what's
going on at this point in time of these
decorated coast band categories and
their applications and so the idea here
is that people in control theory like to
draw diagrams like this where signals
meaning real valued functions of time
move along these sort of metaphorical
wires and then various things can happen
to them they can get added which is
these black triangles they can get
duplicated which is this little Delta
thing here they can get integrated as a
function of time they can get multiplied
by a constant and so on this picture
here is a picture of it of what happens
when you have an upside down pendulum on
a cart and you're you can apply a force
to the cart which is this input and then
the output variables are the angle of
the pendulum and also the position of
the cart and so control theorists use
these diagrams a lot and they can study
the stability of various kinds of
systems by messing around with these
pictures and the differential equations
that these pictures are a kind of code
for and so they however don't seem to
ever talk about the fact that these
pictures are morphisms in in a category
and so that's what this recent work of
various people has been pushing so in
fact we we get a lot of examples of
network languages that is different
kinds of symmetric monoidal categories
and then various symmetric monoidal
functors between them so the one I
talked about in this talk was just this
box FUNKER signing the dynamics to any
open Petri net but you can go further
for example if you're interested in only
in steady states that is situations
where you hold the concentrations of the
inputs and outputs fixed and try to
see what and and look for solutions of
the differential equations that are time
independent there will be typically some
relation that is imposed between the
concentrations and flows of the
chemicals at the inputs and outputs so
you'll get a relation from a Petri net
that describes the steady-state
solutions and so that's a further
simplification of the of the of the
description of what a Petri net is doing
that's only good for telling what's
going on in it if you're only interested
in time independent solutions so that's
a further symmetric monoidal functor
that Blake and I worked out we had
worked out Markov processes but actually
Markov processes can be seen as a
special case of Petri Nets where every
transition just has one input and one
output so that this category here is
embedded in this one there's a way to
reinterpret circuits made of resistors
as Markov processes where you think of
the resistance as the reciprocal of the
rate for something to go either way
across a wire so you get certain Markov
processes with up probably the rate to
hop this way is exactly equal to the
rate to hop that way so you get a
subcategory of Markov processes which
are really the circuits made of
resistors and circuits made of resistors
are a special case of all sorts of other
circuits here maybe I just mean these
passive linear circuits that that
Brendon and I studied and you either for
Markov processes or circuits you can
construct a signal flow diagram so in
control theory they use both circuit
diagrams to describe a like how they'd
actually build an electronic analog
machine but also signal flow diagrams to
more abstractly describe how some
signals are transformed to other signals
so the signal could be either a current
or a potential when you think of it as
coming from us good but then you can go
further and you can actually
this is but what Jason one of the main
things Jason did is he studied how the
signal flow diagrams that the control
theorists use actually give rise to
systems of differential equations their
systems of differential equations which
are linear and their time invariant so
engineers use the Laplace transform to
rewrite them as algebraic equations
sorry linear equations over the field of
functions where you take complex numbers
and throw and one extra variable so
these are rational functions in one
variable the Z's the Laplace transform
variable so if you look at in things in
control theory they love Laplace
transforms and they only to work over
over in that context so this describes
the behavior of a signal flow diagram in
that in the way that control theorists
like but then you can take the steady
states of any signal flow diagram and
you get a relation that just describes
what's going on as things are unchanging
with time and so we have this commuting
diagram maybe commutes up to natural
isomorphism that relates all these
different languages that people have
have looked at so I think this is just
piece of a much bigger puzzle there are
lots of diagram languages that I haven't
gotten into but this is sort of like a
indication of what I what I'd like to do
which is to take these different
languages that various communities have
developed and they don't tend to think
of what they're those languages is
mathematics they tend to think of
mathematics is the stuff that they
learned over in the math courses and
these diagrams is the stuff that they
need to do because to actually get stuff
done but in fact that those diagram
languages I think really are mathematics
and they deserve to be treated with the
with respect because they're very useful
pieces of mathematics so useful that non
mathematicians just have to go out there
and invent them themselves and and so
they I think category theorists are in a
good position to to appreciate how these
different languages fit together into
some bigger bigger structure and I just
want to understand that structure which
you could say is like the the line the
whole story of composition
and all these different disciplines okay
it's all stop here I'm curious why is
there not an arrow from system here no
that's a great question i I there is I
just had never thought about that so so
so when we're down when we're down here
we're only studying the relationship
between inputs and outputs of the system
none of the stuff going on in the middle
the dynamical system that I got from a
Petri net is describing the dynamic the
dynamics not just of the inputs outputs
but also the amounts of stuff in the
middle a signal flow diagram does have
the potential to to do what your what
you're saying because the signal flow
diagram shows in addition to just you
know the inputs and outputs there are
all sorts of other variables in the
middle so you're right we could get a
dynamical system out of it it would be
especially nice kind there'd be a linear
mmm-hmm but that's great thanks hi in
addition to perhaps giving the
scientists general have shockwave
presenting what they already know see
that's that's that's what that's the
curse of being a category theorist in
addition to like clarifying everything
that everyone's doing can you actually
like help them out well so we true
category theorist believes that actually
clarifying things actually does help
people out so you could ask like so what
did set theory ever do for electrical
engineers
sort of I think it actually does
something for electrical engineers to
know that that they're dealing with sets
it may it may not you know suddenly make
a new kind of light bulb but but but it
but it helps them now I would like of
course to give more more the answers
that would satisfy you more but I also
just need to push back against that type
of question because the way I think if
this is is that that it's providing
infrastructure to see that all sorts of
different things are related and and one
and so when you say they're like in
addition to saying to scientists what
they already know you have to realize
that there are lots of the scientists
and they don't all know the same things
so so the example that I like the most
so far is the one I mentioned early on
where it turns out that the that the
chemists have these wonderful theorems
that allow you to deduce the uniqueness
of an equilibrium of a system of
chemical reactions just by looking at
the topology of a chemical reaction
Network but those chemical reaction
networks can be interpreted as Petri
Nets and so those Petri net models can
are also used in other subjects like
evolutionary game theory or the HIV and
so on and so those those people would
never have thought to look in the in the
chemistry literature for for results on
on them so I would be perfectly happy if
I just wrote a textbook that said like
here's how networks work and then like
have tons of examples from all subjects
and then it would start people talking
to each other and then they'd start
trading theorems now of course I also
want to prove my own theorems that
they'll all like but that's another
chance
ok sorry no I'm happy to let you be in
charge of it
from an engineering background we can
usually salvage diagrams in different
ways to solve our problem when we have
one-dimensional problems or ordinary
differential equations but be completely
I haven't seen anyone being able to
generalize this to higher dimension now
oh I think that would be extremely
valuable to give a tool that so that
seamlessly generalizes and you can
actually do partial differential
equations with that and I probably think
it would go to higher categories and
generalize all of these things which as
soon as possible right yeah so I so I've
tried to temporarily shy away from
higher categories to see what I can do
with just one hand tie by my back and
only using symmetric monoidal categories
because there are so many of these
diagram languages where the parts are
basically one-dimensional that is just
bit boxes and wires however we had
discussed this a little bit before in
when you're when you're studying partial
differential equations using finite
element methods these little grids or
cells that people use you should really
think if you want to use this
categorical way of thinking of them you
should be really using higher categories
of some sort and and attempts to squash
that into the one-dimensional language
which people have sometimes made I think
are a little artificial so I think
there's a lot of room there that's right
for a higher category so you've got this
very nice way of not just of describing
these various Network languages for the
blurring with them compositionally
meaning you can take descriptions of
systems and do them together and I think
often in those various disciplines sort
of politically describe a particular
system and then go on and describe
another system exactly if I could find
telling examples where actually the
gluing together itself became you know
out of the was a better way of doing
something designed I think that could
that could actually have a direct that's
right one it's it's somewhat amazing to
me that that the control theorists who
are always drawing these signal flow
diagrams I've never seen not an expert
in the subject but in text books they've
never seemed to discuss composing these
these diagrams they have all sorts of
properties that you calculate from these
diagrams like stability the
controllability the observability of the
system so so what one thing we're
starting to try to do is to look at how
those properties behave under
composition and another example is the
chemical reaction Network literature
deriving properties of chemical
reactions from the topology of the
network organic it like how those behave
under a composition and so that's bound
to be important if you can get any
results of that sort
dynamical systems is it obvious of those
partial differential equations always
have solution and does the diagrammatic
organization helps in setting up the
numeric to actually finding out what's
going on
they don't always have globally defined
solutions you can make a you can make a
Petri net where where say two things of
a type come in to a transition and three
of the same type come out and that would
give you super exponential growth like
DX DT is x squared and that could blow
up in finite amount of time so so so of
course chemistry that would violate
conservation of mass so there are
reasons why that doesn't they're there
reasons why that doesn't happen and you
can study reasons why in reasonable
Petri Nets you do have global existence
in time I think it's really open to the
extent to which compositionality can let
us better analyze the behavior of these
differential equations but I think it's
there's got to be something there so for
example the human body from one
simplification of it is like a huge
network of chemical reactions going on
that are influencing each other and you
have things like certain reactions are
known which act as clocks which that is
which display pure periodic behavior
which then regulate other activities and
trying to understand the whole thing all
at once is not a good way to do it it
can't be that that's how that's the best
way to understand things you want to
understand things sort of in components
portions of the big chemical reaction
Network and how those portions affect
other portions to some extent that's
what biologists are already doing
someone's studying this reaction
someone's telling that reactions on
maybe studying how this one affects that
but but I think it's wide open in terms
of the mathematics how you can formal
hugging improve some theorems about
about how the dynamics of a very
complicated chemical reaction that work
can be deep how qualitative properties
can be determined from qualitative
properties of
parts it's very often qualitative rather
than numerical solutions that you that
you're interested in like these does
something oscillate or not another thing
I I renounced temporarily was any work
on quantum theory I mean I've spent a
lot of time thinking about quantum
theory and also about higher categories
and I decided to temporarily turn a new
leaf so they fit in here okay but but I
don't I'm sort of avoiding thinking
about that right now just a comment and
a question which is called chemical
abstract machine I've heard of it I'm
forgetting a couple of additional
features which I'm not sure how they
could be modern membrane and another
which is freezing eating you can impart
it you can disassemble the real simple
according to a Christian equation which
explained today this is something we do
not create from the attitude work then
later on they introduced something with
each other effective chemical after a
machine whether you have even the
possibility of creating dropping in the
broth let's say new rules of the joint
calculus which is the concurrent
patronage version of Python
so tradition is there enough trivia to
be nice to see if you can impart use
readapting existing categorize if you
have to do something relatively very
more complicated I get your clothes yeah
I'm going to try to get into the more
sophisticated kind of Petri Nets and
analyze them from this point of view
because Blake and I are involved in a
project with a company called Metron
where they actually use a graphical
language for designing complex systems
we use them and their language is
essentially Petri Nets and we're and
we've been sort of recruited to help
help them help think about that more
mathematically and in terms of ugh when
you're talking about membranes so it's a
Gordon has some very nice work on
containers so the idea that the although
the human body's a bunch of chemical
reactions we're not just a single
undifferentiated vat of chemical
reactions there many membranes within
membranes and reactions occurring within
the regions bounded by membranes and
specific rules for how things can pass
through membranes and and that's another
direction I'd really like to go to get
towards more biologically realistic
systems the operation of the restriction
well thanks for the
[Applause]